all right so our next talk
um is from pravish kothari who's talking
about the sum of squares approach to
disentangling gaussian mixtures
take it away all right thanks
uh chris uh are the slides visible
everything good
okay great so um yes so uh thanks to the
organizers for you know
organizing this fantastic workshop and
inviting me to it
so i'm gonna tell you about this recent
line of work on using the sum of squares
method to
cluster measures of gaussians and i'm
actually going to focus mostly on
this uh very recent joint work with my
student anish bakshi at cmu
on clustering non-spherical mixtures
okay so let's begin
all right so you know this is a this is
a talk about an algorithmic problem
so let me describe that problem to you
so
um you know the input to this algorithm
is going to be capital endpoints
these are iid samples from some d
dimensional mixture of k gaussians we're
going to think of
d the dimension as large in the stock so
we are interested in polynomial time
algorithms in this parameter d
we're going to think of k as a constant
and actually believe me
you know for for both mine and your
psychological well-being it's important
to think of k as a constant because i'm
going to show you some atrocious running
times
in two or three slides so k is a
constant
and just to be absolutely clear uh
here's what the model means so there are
like some unknown
sets of parameters let's say mu i sigma
i mean and covariance
and then you know you take gaussian
number one you generate capital n
over k iid points from the gaussian with
those parameters
and call it cluster number one c sub one
you similarly generate c sub two c sub
three c sub k
take the union delete the cluster labels
and you know release the samples to the
algorithm okay
and you know um and of course the
parameters are also unknown to the
algorithm
the goal of the algorithm is to find a
99
accurate clustering of the data here's
what that means the algorithm's job
is to come up with a way to group the
capital n samples it sees
into k equal size buckets so that
each group overlaps with some true
cluster
in at least a 99 uh you know fraction of
its points
okay that's the problem so i'm sure some
of you
are already thinking well you know if
two of the gaussians happen to be very
very close to each other let's say you
know in the extreme case have the exact
same parameters
this is certainly going to be impossible
and indeed it is
and so what i'm going to do is make an
assumption that
every pair of the gaussians is well
separated in a certain sense that i will
soon describe to you okay
so to describe this notion of well
separation
um there are like several options right
like i could choose any notion of
distance between the parameters
and say well you know i'm going to
assume that the gaussians are pairwise
separated in that distance
instead what i'm going to do is you know
state it in a way that
is that makes it apparent that this
notion of distance is the weakest
possible notion
information theoretically speaking and
for that i just need to define
the total variation distance between two
distributions to you so i'm sure all of
you have seen this before
if not it is just up to a scaling of
half the l1 distance between
you know the density functions of the
distributions
it's actually also helpful to think of
this related parameter called as overlap
between the two distributions
which is simply one minus the total
variation distance and both these
quantities are always between zero and
one
okay good so uh with that
definition i can now state my precise
notion of what it means
for uh pairs of gaussians to be well
separated in total variation distance
i say that they are going to be well
separated if the tv distance between
them
grows as one minus something that is
much tinier than one over k
okay in other words the overlap between
every pair of gaussians is at most some
very tiny constant
times one over k okay now
it's legit to think why is it a
reasonable thing to assume
so i want to justify that for just a
second
so for this justification part let's
assume that i make the problem easier
for you
let's assume that you know i give the
true parameters to you i give you mu 1
sigma 1 mu 2 sigma 2 up to mu k sigma k
and i ask you to solve the same problem
okay now that you know the gaussian
distributions
can you cluster the points and you know
you can do various sensible things
any reasonable thing that you will do
looks like the following okay let's take
an example of an algorithm that you
might try in this setting
you know you have the gaussians to under
under under you know all the k possible
gaussians you can compute
the likelihood or the probability of
seeing any point
that is you know inside your samples and
then you know you might want to just
attach the sample to the gaussian that
gives it the maximum probability
okay this is just one thing you can do
you can do various variants of it
but what you can prove is that in any
reasonable variant of this
the points that you will misclassify the
number of points the fraction of point
that will misclassify
equals um the the sum
of the overlaps of any cluster with all
the remaining k
minus one clusters okay i'm going to
just state that by fiat not at all
try to argue it but in particular that's
the reason that i'm choosing the
overlaps to be much
smaller than one over k because now the
sum of the overlaps is going to be much
tinier than some
fixed constant which means that it is
reasonable information theoretically
to ask to find a 99 percent accurate
clustering
okay so that's that's the problem we're
going to look at today good
so okay what about this problem well
there is this
very nice and famous algorithm that came
out about 10 years ago
uh due to collimator valiant moisture
valiant and then belkin and sinha
who gave a d to the polynomial in k
algorithm
to do parameter estimation that's
basically learn the parameters of a
mixtures of k gaussian
by exploiting certain polynomial
relationships that hold between moments
of univariate gaussians
okay in particular you can actually use
this algorithm
to cluster uh you know measures of
gaussians
under certain regimes but in fact i'll
argue to you in about 10 minutes or so
that i
to the best of my understanding there
are clusterable mixtures of gaussians
that this algorithm actually cannot
cluster
regardless you know it kind of handles
lots of interesting cases already so
it's a very interesting algorithm that
solves you know
um you know um many
many different kinds of clusterable
measures of gaussians
and so you know a natural question is
what am i doing here
this problem seems kind of almost solved
and so the reason is that i am actually
looking at a variant of this problem
today
i'm looking at a harsher variant the
so-called outlier
robust variant of this problem here's
what that means
the setting is the same you know
somebody generates an iid sample from
the mixture as i described earlier
but this time you don't get to see those
samples instead an adversary you know
intercepts these samples and they get to
change an arbitrary epsilon fraction of
the samples
by whatever they like and of course you
know they're trying to make your life
harder so they'll they'll you know use
adversarially worst case uh you know
points to replace the epsilon fraction
of the samples they want to work with
okay so this time you're given these y
eyes with the only guarantee that y is
intersect with some
unknown true iid sample in one minus
epsilon fraction
and your goal is still to cluster but
let's be a little bit more careful about
what kind of guarantees we can expect
okay because an adversary can corrupt an
epsilon fraction
of the samples one thing they can do is
like you know force all this epsilon
fraction of the outliers
into one of the two clusters and because
the true cluster has weight one over k
these outliers constitute a k times
epsilon fraction
of the points in that cluster which
means that if i am sensibly asking
for algorithm to do something reasonable
then you know i have to allow it to
misclassify about k
times epsilon fraction of the samples so
that's what would be our that's what the
goal would be okay we would want to get
a clustering which is accurate up to 1
minus you know k epsilon samples
we're going to work with epsilon much
tinier than 1 over k and as i convinced
you earlier we're going to think of it
as a constant
so you know no harm no foul so far good
so that's our goal and so uh you know
one thing you could
immediately ask is what about this
algorithm i just showed you which kind
of works in many cases
well you know i don't want to like
mathematically justify it or anything
but
because it exploits algebraic
relationships between moments of
gaussians
it which involves like solving some
system of polynomial equations
it turns out that it's kind of hard to
make this algorithm with some
you know robust with some modest
modification into a robust algorithm
okay um and so that's the reason that
you know uh two years ago in another
assignments program
daikon nicolas venpala and woodruff
asked for
you know designing a outlier robust
efficient algorithm
for clustering you know this tv
separated mixtures of k gaussians
and so you know in this talk basically
what i'm telling you is a solution to
that problem
uh it's a polynomial time algorithm
to outlier robustly cluster all
clusterable measures of k gaussians
um the running time is atrocious it's d
to the k to the o of k
but you know i prepared you for this
moment k is a constant so this is a
polynomial
all good uh what i really like about
this algorithm though you know it's
great you know we solved some nice
questions that's that's fine
what i really like is that it's a truly
new algorithm what do i mean by that
any algorithm has to come up with
properties of the gaussian distribution
to exploit
and i told you before that this
polynomial relationship this algorithm
of belkan sinha kalimanta valiant and
matra valiant
it exploits you know some relationship
between how the movements of univariate
gaussians are related to each other
okay and as i said you know it kind of
looks hard to you know make such an
algorithm into a robust one
what we do here is come up with a new
algorithm
that exploits instead of algebraic
properties of this polynomial
relationships form
instead it exploits analytic properties
in fact it exploits two
quite nice and uh simple analytic
properties
uh called hyper contractivity and
anti-concentration actually it needs
certifiable variants of it which
actually i realize i'm never going to
get to in this talk so sorry about that
but i'll explain to this to you what
these properties mean okay so
hypercontractivity is a certain
statement about
concentration in the distribution so in
particular what it means is that
if you take any degree two polynomial of
the gaussian distribution
then the higher moments of it can be
controlled can be bounded in terms of
you know the second moment
what powers of the second moment so it's
a certain concentration statement
the second statement is almost like an
antithesis of it it's an
requirement what that means is that if
you take the gaussian distribution
project it into any direction so take
like
a directional marginal of it then
the probability that this 1d
distribution stays inside any
small interval is small okay
so again i don't want to discuss the
quantitative variance of it just now
but what we prove is that if you have
any distribution that have this
certifiable or algorithmic counterparts
of these two concentration
and anti-concentration properties then
in fact you know you can
cluster uh any mixture of them okay
and so you know it's not like we can
capture lots of
interesting distributions in this
definition right now unfortunately
i still like the fact that we can
abstract out these two properties
but one mixture other than gaussians
that we can handle
if you were thinking about that is uh
you know let's take
yesterday you take uniform distribution
on the sphere and take affine transforms
of it
and then take mixtures of these affine
transforms well you know in a black box
way the theorem i'm going to say
i'm sitting for you actually also yields
an algorithm for clustering such
mixtures
okay um anyway so that you know that's
that's the result i'm going to talk
about and this result you know uses the
sum of squares method
but before i go further i want to
mention that you know there is an
independent work
of daikon nicolas uh sam hopkins who's
around in the skull
um uh dan kane and sushrut karmalkar
who also get a similar result for the
special case of gaussians
their algorithm is also a polynomial
time just like ours
okay great so that's the result i'm
gonna tell you a little bit more about
today
um but you know i have to include the
mandatory motivation slides
actually i'm going to you know skip
through most of them but i just want to
you know
show you that they exist so you know
this slide tells you that this is an
important problem
i'm sure you know and there is a
mandatory picture of carl pearson in
there so i'm sure you're convinced
so let me not you know spend too much
time on it actually maybe i need to
spend some time on justifying why i'm
looking at robust algorithms
uh you know uh so let me you know do
that so you know robust estimation and
like designing algorithms that are
robust to various assumptions you make
on data is of course like a very long
uh you know it has been a problem that
has been studied for very very uh you
know
uh uh for for a long time by
statisticians mostly
and efficient counterparts of this you
know uh were somehow you know
started getting looked at very seriously
in this two starting with this two very
interesting papers that came out about
five years ago
and this paper is of course part of the
same gravy train uh just like a whole
whole list of you know follow-up works
which i cannot list
uh on this one slide so i'm not gonna do
i'm not going to try
but you know i don't want to justify a
robust estimation just by the intrinsic
motivations of you know designing robust
algorithms
instead i want to give you i want to
sketch an argument for you
why you should care about this problem
even if you know you were just an
algorithm designer who didn't care about
so much about you know robust estimation
and the argument you know is that you
know just like
any other measure of goodness of
algorithms like approximation ratios
running times
space complexity whatever outlier
robustness is a property that inspires
truly new algorithmic ideas you know
which presumably as a theorist is all
you care about you know what
what's the problem that forces you to
think about new algorithms
and uh actually you know beyond just
that it actually you know makes you come
up with uh insights that
you know you know otherwise would have
been you know somewhat hard to come up
with
and so a couple of them are listed on
the slide again i don't want to spend
too much time
say short talk i'm going to tell you
about the results but you know the third
part is kind of important in our context
you know i told you earlier that there
was this algorithm of belkan sinha
kalimoth revaliant and mata valiant that
uses algebraic structure to solve a
similar problem in the non-outlier
robust case
and the key to our result today is going
to be you know come up with an algorithm
that exploits analytic properties
instead
and in fact you know um i won't get to
tell you much about the algorithm
but here is one thing i can tell you the
entire paper
you know like 90 of it is focused
entirely on solving the non-outlier
reverse problem
because once you do that the case of you
know handling outliers becomes almost
like an afterthought to it like just
some syntactic notational changes giving
the outlier robustness
so that's in some sense you know in in
the argument that is sketched in the
slide that you know somehow if you come
up with the right algorithm
it will have this robustness properties
perhaps with only some tiny bit of
modifications
and so you know if you're an algorithm
designer think of it as like one more
constraint that you want to maintain
which helps you think about like new
ideas for designing algorithms
good that's my uh argument that's my
motivation anyway
so in the remaining part of this talk
which is like i think ten
or nine minutes uh i'm going to tell you
something interesting
uh unfortunately i tried very hard but
there's not going to be any sum of
squares in it
uh i'll include something in the last
slide sorry about that
instead you know i hopefully tell you
some some interesting you know pictorial
facts like geometry
facts which you know hopefully you enjoy
so
what i want to do in the first part of
the talk is explain to you
what does it mean for a pair of
gaussians to be separated in total
variation distance
you know i have if i have to visualize
it i would like to somehow view it as
some kind of distance between the
parameters of the gaussian
so i explained to you you know how you
can think about this separation notion
and this will also allow me to you know
point out cases where to the best of my
understanding
i think the moisture valiant and kali
metropolitan algorithms do not work in
the
for the clustering problem i'll describe
like a very important case where it
actually fails
um and then you know i'll i'll
quantificate for two minutes about
what we do new um this would be
rather understandable but hopefully i'll
convince you that this
anti-concentration property that i
mentioned before is relevant
and then you know uh i'll stop and
uh if there are questions i'll you know
go into details of any of these things
okay that's my plan for today good so
let's see you know
uh how we can understand geometrically
uh the notion of two gaussians being you
know separated
so here's the fact okay here's the fact
that in fact
we prove in this paper if two gaussians
if two gaussian distributions are
separated
in total variation distance in this
weirdly parameterized way
so one minus exponential in minus delta
square log delta for some parameter
delta
and you know permit me to have you know
this this weird parameterization because
it will make
the statements that come next easier to
be easier
so two gaussians are pairwise tv
separated
via you know by this by this one minus
exponentially minus delta square log
delta
if they are if and only if they have
separation that holds in one of the
following
three parameter distance ways okay
the first is separation because of
means being far apart okay here is what
it means and actually let me explain the
pictures i'm going to draw because
i think they're they're kind of
instructed so i'm going to think of you
know two-dimensional
two-dimensional gaussians i'm going to
you know draw ellipses for each of these
gaussians the center of the ellipses
denote the mean
and you know the the psd matrices sigma
i you know draw these
ellipses around it so one way to think
about it is that you know if you look at
the extent of this ellipse the distance
of this
any point of the ellipse you know to the
center
then it tells you the variance of that
gaussian you know in that direction
okay in the in the 2d space good so here
is what it means for two gaussians to be
mean separated it means that there is a
direction
let's say v and v is the normal vector
to this hyper plane that i'm drawing
well it's it's a line here but you know
imagine higher dimensional version in
which case it would be hyper plane
it means that if there is there is a
direction v so that if i project the
distribution down into this direction
and take the distance between the means
in this direction
then it is multiplicatively larger
than the sum of the variances of the two
gaussian
in that direction okay so the right hand
side is the sum of the variances of the
two gaussian v transpose sigma i plus
sigma jv
and this condition says that if i look
at the mean distance
in this direction then it's like
multiplicatively larger than the sum of
the variances
okay in fact you know this case is very
well studied the trend like we wrote
some papers about discussing missions of
spherical gaussians in 2018
and in some sense that's the kind of
separation that these papers handle
okay and perhaps like most of the
attention so far has been focused on the
mean separated case
okay so i won't spend too much time on
it because i want to tell you two
interesting other ways which
you know are also uh you know what
generate tv distance
but are not really handled by previous
works
and here is like you know one cool
notion it's the sp
i call it the spectral separation here
is what it means in our 2d
diagram that we've been drawing imagine
that the green and red gaussians have
the exact same means now
okay so their means are equal and their
variances in the horizontal direction
are also equal
but in the vertical direction the red
gaussian
has a multiplicatively higher variance
than the green gaussian
okay by a factor of delta okay
it turns out that in that case the
gaussians are also
tv separated okay now here is one
extreme
parameter regime of this notion of
distance which is very important for us
imagine that one of the gaussians here
in fact has
zero variance in the vertical direction
let's say the green gaussian has zero
variance
okay its covariance is rank deficient
while the red gaussian has
non-zero but arbitrarily tiny variance
in the same direction
this spectral separation notion is
telling you that in that case
the two gaussians are separated in a tv
sense of one so they're like maximally
separated in tb distance
and the important thing is that this
holds even though the red gaussians
variance could be
arbitrarily tiny non-zero number
okay in particular notice that the
parameter distance like if you compute
any possible norm of sigma minus sigma i
minus sigma j
it's going to be you know arbitrarily
tiny and yet in total variation distance
the two gaussians are separated by
one okay so one very nice case
one very nice example of such mixtures
of gaussians is the
subspace clustering problem here is what
the problem is if you not heard about it
you are given a mixture of k gaussians
each of them have mean 0
each of the each of the covariances are
basically projection matrices to
distinct subspaces as long as the
subspaces are distinct
however close they might be to each
other as long as they're distinct
the pairwise tv separation between them
is one notice that the parameter
separation any natural norm of the
covariance difference is going to be
arbitrarily tiny and yet they are tv
separated by one
this is the case that to the best of my
understanding
the kali micro valiant and multivitamin
papers do not handle because they give
parameter distance guarantees and in
particular i don't think that you know
the algorithm can be used to cluster
that's what you know we are going to be
able to solve today
okay so that's great uh but you know i'm
not done there is a
third way that two gaussians can be
separated in tv distance
the two the first two things you know
were legit to draw in two dimensions
because there are two dimensional
gaussians that can be tv separated
in either mean way or the spectral way
that i described
but this third notion is impossible to
draw in 2d this is a truly high
dimensional way that two gaussians can
be tv separated
here is what it means and like i implore
you to ignore the formula that appears
at the top
okay instead focus only on the picture
imagine that you have
red gaussian and green gaussian but this
time they're in high dimension so i'm
only drawing like a projection in 2d now
and they basically have variances that
differ slightly let's say in every
direction but in any given direction
their variances are arbitrarily close in
fact as you push d to infinity
the two gaussians have essentially the
same variance in every single direction
yet they are going to be tv separated as
long as you know the
separation in any single direction you
know is larger than this one over or
like some
big constant over root d okay that's
that's all i'm going to say here
and this is the relative frobenius way
of two gaussians being
pairwise tv separated
okay all right so i just described to
you three ways of being tv separated
um and so here is the fact i started
writing down earlier let me complete it
now
the fact says that two gaussians are tv
separated
then you know the following one of the
three possible ways of being
uh parameter separated must hold the
converse is actually easy to prove so
this is in some sort of higher direction
and it seems that this fact is also not
that hard to prove it's completely
elementary we just you know work by
passing on to the hell in your distance
and use the fact that there is like a
closed form formula for the hellinger
distance between
any two gaussians okay so i'm not going
to tell you this proof but that's
uh that's that's uh you know that's the
parameter way to understand tv
separation
uh good so let me
uh uh let me make this comment you know
for the spherical case as i said you
know we only needed to handle the mean
separation that was basically what we
did in 2018
uh the new things that we have to handle
were really in the non-spherical case
was the spectral separation and relative
robinius separation
and actually it turns out at least to me
the hardest case here is handling the
spectral separation which is some sense
the the truly new piece here good
so as i promised to you in uh the
remaining
is there is there time remaining i guess
i have one minute
well you know you can take a
two or three minutes to finish okay yeah
so yeah this is the pontificating part
so i'm not going to tell you anything
great
i'll just point out one uh you know cool
point okay
so uh for the mean separated case it
turns out
so you know any any algorithm let me
make this
following comment like any algorithm
that you know solves the clustering
problem for some distribution
has to come up with some properties of
that distribution
to exploit like somehow you know you you
have to find a way
to separate true clusters from fake
clusters so you must check some property
of which holds for true clusters let's
say gaussian clusters
this does not hold you know if you you
know if you take fake clusters
you must come up with some property in
the mean separated case that we handled
in 2018 this property
turned out to be sub gaussian
directional moments the fact that you
know if i project the distribution into
any single direction
and compute higher moments they can be
upper bounded in terms of the lower
moments
okay it turns out that for the two other
kinds of separation that i just showed
you this
moment upper bound is probably not
enough okay
in fact in a longer talk i give you a
very simple example which demonstrates
this i will not give you this example
today
but it turns out that one key method
that
allows us to handle this case
algorithmically is to come up with this
way to you know exploit
anti-concentration algorithmically
and thankfully you know in this previous
sequence of works
we were able to develop this idea of
certifiable anti-concentration
which somehow turns out to be the key
piece in you know handling spectral
separated
gaussians so anyway like all i want to
say is that you know moment upper bounds
are not enough you have to come up with
some ways to
exploit moment lower bounds and this
anti-concentration property of gaussians
is somehow crucial there in fact not
just crucial but necessary
all right so that's all i want to say um
i've never not not told you at all about
what this algorithm is but it's
you know the sum of squares algorithm
i'm sure you know of it
um you know in my previous talks i all i
used to say
is like these steps one two three uh but
it turns out that in this particular
work all the steps were kind of
non-trivial so let me not somehow say
that
steps two and three are easy instead let
me just point you to you know sources
for learning more about this
so we wrote this monograph uh last year
which you can you know uh
check out that in fact we uh you know
include an exposition for the spherical
mixture case
um and you know if you're so interested
in learning more about this method in
detail then i'm actually teaching a
class right now
fall 20 and it's completely online and
you can ask me for a zoom link to it
good all right that's all i want to say
there are cool open questions which i
will leave it on the slide
thank you very much privilege so there
are a couple questions in the queue
i'm first going to unmute andres corrada
who asks a question or two in the q a ah
okay
andres hi yes so i so i'm struck by the
algebraic similarity between
uh so first of all what i'm what i'm
comparing is you're talking about
clustering so i'm not talking about
clustering i'm talking i'm going back to
my
uh you know also the ground truth
inference problem right which is
given that you're now have n noisy
teachers which are
you know uh you know you know spiky
gaussians right
about the ground truth could you recover
their error covariance so that then you
can you know recombine them and get back
the ground truth right so that's the
problem and
of course the only way to do this
non-parametrically without knowing
anything about the distributions
is to use moments of the data that
you're given
and those are out the algebraic
relations
right and and so that allows the problem
to be solved
so that's that that's what i'm i mean
there and so but i'm really interested
because the
the algebraic problem then has can only
be solved
it's always short right the algebraic
relationships cannot tell you
everything and they tend to be end short
so when the problem goes
when the noisy sources of ground truth
are not sparsely correlated
you start not being able to solve it so
i'm really interested in your not
uh analytic approach so i i really like
that references you gave
uh at the end and i'm gonna read those
thank you
yeah i mean you know i i'm sorry for
like giving you essentially
information free talk like it's all buzz
words no information
but you know i'm happy to you know um
point you to videos for like longer
talks that i gave on this and i yeah
uh i think uh yeah any of the sources or
any of the questions you might have i'll
be very happy to you know
you know exchange emails and clarify
thanks so much for the interest
um sam do you want to ask your question
yeah sure although uh somebody has been
clarifying it to me offline but others
might have the same question
um which is in pravesh can you give some
example
in the case where moisture valiant can't
do clustering
um of a set of parameters that they
would be allowed to return but
where you wouldn't be able to use those
parameters to do
clustering trivially because i thought
that they give guarantees
in in total variation distance
so to the best of my understanding their
guarantees are
in uh parameter distance what that means
uh is
that um you know uh you know they can
give you some arbitrarily like you know
there is a parameter epsilon let's say
and then they can give you estimates of
the mean which are accurate to l2
distance
within let's say epsilon and uh
estimates of
covariances which are accurate to you
know forbidden systems of epsilon
and when you know you have bounds on
let's say
when you have bounce on
okay let's put it this way you know
suppose uh so
let's take an example right let's say
that i give you a measure of two
gaussians
um they have uh you know zero means and
uh their covariances are projections two
subspaces
now imagine that the subspaces are same
dimensions and they're like basically
tiny perturbations of each other
yeah okay which means this is one the
tibia distance is one
and in some sense you know the way uh we
would
exhibit this tv distance is by showing a
direction in which you know one of the
gaussians
you know basically has zero variance
while the other one will have like a
non-zero variance
but the point is that you know the
parameter distance between these two
gaussians is
you know arbitrarily tiny which means
that if all you give me
is an estimate of the covariance which
is accurate with an epsilon name for
being resistance
that's not going to distinguish that's
not going to allow me to you know
distinguish between points from these
two subspace gaussians
so a natural idea that like in their
paper is to
so-called isotopize the gaussians like
you know compute the covariance of the
mixture and then you know put the
mixture in the isotropic position in
that
view what fails in my opinion is
if you look at the new covariances they
will have
you know some eigenvalues which would be
very very tiny and some eigenvalues will
be very very large
and the point is that a fixed uh
parameter distance of epsilon will not
be enough to recover
the tiny eigenvalues in you know the
relevant notion of distance
so maybe those are the two ways to
understand why parameter distance
approaches will not be able to cluster
you know these arbitrarily close
subspace examples
thanks yeah let me give a shout out to
anish who has been clarifying this to me
offline
uh and experience it also took us a
while to figure this out
uh but yeah that makes sense now
um if i could ask something yes
um so i mean the the sort of uh
approaches by
uh mutual valiant and others that you
point to these are like method of
movements type approaches right these
have a very long history in statistics
yes
um i to my understanding one reason why
people love them is because
they often perform well at least in low
dimensions even if you are a bit far
away from distributional assumptions
right
so you don't really need normality for
everything to work so i'm wondering
you know the approach that you sort of
were suggesting of actually exploiting
distributional properties
is that really sort of robust in that in
high dimensions if you have
distributions which are not mixtures of
gaussians but distributions that are
close to gaussians
would you still expect your approach to
work
i want to say the answer is yes and in
fact okay some of the robustness is
always in the eye of the beholder but
you know i think in a precise sense this
approach i would say is more robust
and so the reason i would say that is
the following so
um you know actually you know so let me
make one point clear before even going
ahead
our algorithm in the end is also
exploiting properties
that can be derived from moments but i
guess the point we are making is that
you don't need
equality of moment so you don't need you
know satisfying this moment
relationships you know
up to this polynomial relationship that
are true in fact we are saying that you
know
we only need the moments up to
the fact that they imply these two nice
analytic properties
so one is the hyper contractivity
property of degree two polynomials and
other is the anti-concentration property
in particular if you perturb the moments
they will continue to satisfy these
properties in fact i'm going to say that
you know you can design very natural
perturbations which will
kill the polynomial relationship between
you know sure
i guess i'm wondering how robust the
anti-concentration and the
hyper-contractive properties are right
these are usually things that we
hear about in the context of gaussian
distributions right
right and so uh okay so the other way i
can
potentially answer that question is by
giving you other distributions that the
same algorithm works for
i guess when i gave you one example
early on which is you know affine
transforms of uniform distribution on
the sphere
you could come up with other examples i
mean there are certainly many more
examples of distributions which are
hyper-contractive and anti-concentrated
unfortunately our algorithm doesn't work
because we need certifiable
counterparts and in some sense yeah for
those we only have this limited set of
examples
but but also notice that if you get if
you if you get samples from a
distribution which is only
epsilon or you know one minus epsilon
close in total variation to an actual
mixture of gaussians the whole point of
professor's algorithm is it will work
right because any tv perturbation is
okay as long as you make
as long as the tv distance is one over k
you know like you don't have to think of
them as outliers at sam's point you know
you could think of them as a mixture of
distributions each of which is like one
minus one over k
square close and t v distance to
gaussians but no other guarantees
so perturbations in tb distance are okay
is the message okay
for the individual distributions yes
so so pravesh your your lemma about the
these three alternatives for
uh two gaussians that have variation
distance
it seems like the one way to state that
is that
any time two gaussians have a noticeable
variation distance there is a separator
which is either a hyperplane
or a pair of hyperplanes that are
parallel or an ellipsoid whose shape is
given by one of the two
is that is that another way to put it so
that you have these
algorithmically derivable separators
from the parameters
yes absolutely yes in fact you know uh
one
one alternate method that i think one
alternate way that people have
uh stated this or maybe like sam's paper
states this is
um that if two gaussians are separated
in variation distance
then either there is a linear polynomial
that somehow noticeably different on the
two distributions
or there is a quadratic polynomial that
is noticeably different in the two
uh distributions so the quadratic
polynomial is of two forms just to
remind you
uh one of them comes from the spectral
separation in which case the quadratic
polynomial looks like square of a linear
form
and um uh in the third way the relative
convenience way the the polynomial is
like truly high rank like you know
it's the coefficient matrix is going to
be truly high rank
if that makes sense but yes yes you can
you can characterize this
notion of distance in that way okay
um so there are a couple other questions
from andres but i think maybe they could
be taken offline so that we can have a
120 second break before sam's talk
but thank you very much again pravish
thank you